FEMALE SPEAKER: Hi, everyone,
and thank you for coming.
I'm so excited to introduce
Jane Chen, who's the
co-founder of Embrace.
As she'll tell you shortly,
Jane is saving millions of
lives with an incubator that
sells for 1% of the
traditional cost.
Her mission is to create
innovations that represent a
new trend in technology--
simple, localized, affordable
solutions that have the
potential to make huge
social impacts.
Prior to Embrace, Jane worked
with nonprofit organizations
on health care issues in several
developing countries.
She spent several years as the
program director of a startup
HIV AIDS nonprofit in China,
and worked for the Clinton
Foundations Initiative
in Tanzania.
She also worked at Monitor
Group as a management
consultant.
Chen has been selected as
TEDIndia fellow, a TED senior
fellow, an Echoing Green
fellow, and a
Rainier Arnold fellow.
Recently, she was also named a
young global leader by the
World Economic Forum.
She holds an MBA from Stanford
University and a master's in
public administration
from Harvard.
With that, let's all welcome
Jane, who will be speaking
about embracing life.
JANE CHEN: Thank you
so much for being
here on a Friday afternoon.
So I wanted to start
by walking you
through a quick exercise.
I'll ask everyone to
play along here.
Please close your eyes
and open your
hands in front of you.
Now imagine for a moment
what you could
place in your hands--
your keys, maybe an apple.
Now open your eyes.
What about a life?
What you see here is
a premature baby.
He looks like he's sleeping
peacefully, when in fact, he's
struggling to stay alive because
he can't regulate his
own body temperature.
There are millions of babies
like this born every year
around the world and the mission
of Embrace is to give
these babies a chance to survive
through a low cost
infant warmer.
Embrace is a social enterprise
that aims to provide a line of
innovative and affordable
medical devices for emerging
markets, starting with
our warmer, and
was started at Stanford.
Back in 2007, when I was doing
my MBA, I took a class there
called Design for Extreme
Affordability, which is half
MBAs and half engineers.
And we were given the challenge
to build a baby
incubator that cost less than
1% of the cost of a
traditional incubator, which
is $20,000 in the US.
My own background before
business school, I was doing
HIV AIDS work first in China
and then in Africa.
And through those sets of
experiences, I saw these huge
health care disparities
in developed
versus developing countries.
In the US, anyone who needs AIDS
medication can get it.
But in places in China and
Africa, this was virtually
impossible.
So I saw many people who lost
their lives or children who
lost their parents because they
weren't able to access
these medications.
And the most frustrating part of
this, to me, was that these
are medications that exist and
these are people that were
dying for preventable causes.
So Embrace has become a platform
for me and my team to
try to bridge that disparity
in health care.
And up here are my three
co-founders, who I've been
incredibly fortunate
to work with.
So I wanted to walk you through
some of the design
process that we used
to develop Embrace.
There's a lot of talk about
design thinking these days,
and I think it's really just
a fancy way of saying
humancentric design that's
very experimental.
As I'll walk you through each
of the steps, first is to
really understand the problem
at hand, to be out where the
problem is, to observe it, and
develop that user empathy.
And defining the problem is
the most important step in
this entire process.
It seems very simple, but that's
what paves the way for
human centered product
development.
And there's ideating,
prototyping, and finally
testing, and this is all
an iterative process.
So the first step for us was
to really understand the
background of the problem.
There are 20 million low birth
weight and premature babies
born every year around
the world.
Four million babies die in the
first 28 days of their life.
That's 450 babies every hour.
One of the biggest problems
they face is staying warm.
Because they're so tiny, they
don't have enough body fat to
regulate their own
temperature.
And for this reason, many either
die or they grow up
with extreme long term
health problems.
Incubators, of course,
are the most common
solution to this problem.
But not only are they expensive,
they require a
constant supply of electricity,
so you're not
going to find them in rural
areas where most of these
babies are dying.
And instead what you see are
light bulbs-- light bulbs are
the most common solution out
there, but in every clinic
I've been to that uses a light
bulb, you hear stories of them
shattering over babies because
of problems with the circuits.
Or you see parents who tie hot
water bottles surround their
babies' bodies or hold them over
hot coals-- so, really
unsafe, ineffective solutions.
From there, we went to
the observe phase.
So we went across the length and
breadth of India talking
to mothers, midwives, doctors,
community health care workers,
trying to understand the
root of the problem.
And we heard stories
like this.
This is a woman that
I met on one of my
first visits to India.
She lives in a village
in Maharastra.
And she had given birth to a
tiny baby girl and had taken
this girl to the village
doctor to be
placed in an incubator.
The doctor advised her to take
her baby to the nearest city
hospital that was over four
hours away, and she didn't
have the means to get there,
so her baby died
as a result of that.
And we heard this story
over and over again.
We also heard stories
like this one.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
JANE CHEN: Sujatha lost all
three of her babies.
And again, in every village
I've been to in India, you
hear the same story over
and over again.
And so it was based on research
like this that we
realized the problem wasn't
serving doctors
and big city hospitals.
We needed a product that could
get to women like Sujatha.
In India, 50% of births take
place in a home setting.
In countries like Bangladesh,
that number is as high as 90%.
And so we defined the problem,
and thought about the user as
a desperate parent in a remote
village without resources to
access a major hospital with
the need being the means to
give their dying baby
a chance to survive.
And so with that, we realized
that we needed a product that
could work without a constant
supply of electricity, that
has no moving parts, that is
portable, that's safe and
intuitive to use so even a
mother or midwife could use
it, and something that would
allow for close mother to
child interaction.
So we begin prototyping.
You can see all the different
ideas we had, ranging from a
hot water incubator to a tent
like device to a maternity
vest that my colleague Linus
is nicely modeling here.
And the idea that we like the
best that fit our criteria was
that of a little sleeping bag
that uses a phase change
material, a wax like substance,
to keep the baby at
a constant temperature.
And I'll show you the final
device and then some of the
evolution of getting
to that point.
So this is the Embrace Nest.
As you can see, it looks
like a little
sleeping bag for a baby.
It's made out of entirely
waterproof materials, so you
can clean it easily between
every baby.
It's reusable.
But The core technology
sits in the back here.
So this is a pouch of
what's called a
phase change material.
It's a wax like substance.
You can heat this either with
boiling water or with an
electric heater.
But the key is once melted,
it stays at the exact same
temperature for up to eight
hours at a time, after which
you can simply reheat it.
So I'll pass this around.
And it looks like a very
simple device, but it's
actually taken hundreds
of iterations
to get to this point.
This is the very first
prototype--
very cliche, but the drawings
are on the back of a napkin,
and we used margarine
to prototype.
It has very similar qualities
to the wax.
And then the first renditions
of this, we actually had a
product-- we just went to a
Salvation Army, found all the
relevant baby gear, and the
very first version of the
product actually has a tube
running through it that you
pour boiling water into
that melts the wax.
And then someone said to us,
it's probably not a good idea
to boiling water right next to
the baby's head, so we quickly
scrapped that idea.
Then we went to a second
version here.
We realized that babies in these
countries don't wear
diapers, so we needed something
that was really easy
to clean and that
was waterproof.
This is where we started moving
to those materials.
I'm going to skip a
few of these here.
This one's really interesting,
because initially we had it
such that the wax would just sit
right inside the sleeping
bag and the baby would
lie on top of that.
The wax is food grade, it's
completely nontoxic, that
would be totally safe.
But there is this perception
of fear from mothers of the
wax leaking onto the baby, and
so that led us to create a
separate compartment that you
see in this current edition
where the wax sits.
Because cleanliness is so
critical-- you don't want
cross infection across
babies--
we created this sleeping bag out
of one piece of fabric, so
there are almost no seams
in there, so dirt
can't collect inside.
You see a little plastic window
in the front there This
is something doctors were
requesting, because they
wanted to monitor the baby's
breathing and color, and so we
added that in.
This is a picture of
my nephew that I
stuffed into the device.
We show it, because user testing
is key, so use your
family members if necessary.
And this is an interesting
story.
So on the wax pouch, what you'll
see is a temperature
indicator that tells you when
the pouch needs to be reheated
or when it's too cold
or too hot.
And initially we had a numeric
scale going from about 30 to
40 degrees Celsius.
But as we went in villages and
tested this, mothers would say
to us we don't trust
Western medicine.
If you give me a certain dosage
of medicine to give to
my baby, I'll cut in half
because it's too strong.
So if you told me to keep this
at 37 degrees Celsius, I'll
keep it at a little less
than that, because it's
probably too warm.
So it's something we certainly
didn't expect to hear sitting
in Palo Alto.
But that led us to this version
of the design, which
is a happy face,
frowning face.
And now it's just simply
a OK, not OK.
So, just really simple cultural
nuances have had a
huge impact on the way we've
gone about designing the
device and making it
really locally
appropriate to these markets.
And from there, we
went to testing.
So this is the very first low
birth weight baby Nisha that
was placed in the device.
And since then, we've done
randomized controlled trials
now and across over 200 babies
showing that our product is as
safe and efficacious as a
standard of care, even in a
tertiary level setting.
So our progress to date-- our
product is available in
hospitals across south India
with initial pilots being done
across seven countries.
As I mentioned, we have
multi-center studies completed.
We have an ISO 1345
certification, meaning that we
meet international standards
with both regards to
manufacturing and design.
We have a global partnership
established with GE
Healthcare.
They're our largest global
distributor.
And Embrace has been recognized
as one of the top
innovations by the World
Health Organization.
But what's been most exciting
is seeing our product in use
in the field and the impact
that it's having on lives.
This is one of the very first
babies to use the device.
This is an 850 gram baby,
less than two pounds.
And when I went to the hospital,
the doctor said to
me, there's no way this baby's
going to survive.
And If it weren't for your
product I would just
leave him to die.
I went back two weeks after this
photograph was taken and
the baby was still alive.
Two weeks after that, he was
sent home with his parents.
This a woman named Mandala who
gave birth to baby slightly
over two pounds.
Mandala lost her first two
babies, as is so often the
case in the women
that we help.
And in this case, what was
wonderful is that you could
see Mandala's confidence
starting to come back as her
baby gained her health.
And in many of these settings,
what happens is not only do
women lose their babies, but
they are blamed by their
communities for the loss
of their babies.
And oftentimes their families,
their husband's families, will
pressure him to leave
her if she can not
produce a healthy baby.
So there's a really important
aspect to this work which goes
beyond saving babies, and that's
empowering these women.
This is one of my favorite
stories.
This is a woman named Kurthi.
Kurthi also lost her first
baby and gave birth to a
second, a 3 and 1/2 pound baby,
who was placed in our
product for about seven
days' time.
And I went back and visited
Kurthi a few months later.
You can see now the baby's nice
and healthy, very chubby.
And she'd gone back and
told her entire
village about Embrace.
Even the 110 year old great
grandmother knew about the
product and did a little
dance to thank us
as we left her home.
And this is another
favorite story of
mine, which is in China.
I just visited this orphanage
that we're working
with two weeks ago.
And this is baby Long.
He was born about seven
months ago.
He was two pounds when
they found him.
This is an orphanage that
rescues abandoned babies.
They brought him to the
orphanage and kept him in our
product for about 30 days.
And this is baby Long
seven months later.
You can see that he's healthy,
he's very happy, very
interactive.
And they informed me that this
was the first time a baby of
this size had survived
in the orphanage.
These are some snapshots
of our product being
used around the world.
And what's been really, really
exciting is seeing the product
go from this to this, which is
now a standard of care in many
of these settings.
So this is just the
start for us.
Over the next five
years, we hope to
impact a million lives.
And we continue to get requests
every day from people
all over the world asking when
can we buy this product?
I won't go into all of these,
but I'll read one in
particular that's always
touched my heart.
It's a woman from Uganda who
says, the majority of
premature babies are never given
a chance to make it out
of the hospitals--
sorry, it's hard for
me to read this.
Because there are no incubators,
they are left to
die without the comforting
touch of their mothers in
those final moments.
And they're placed directly
in the trash can.
So we get stories, requests,
like this every day that just
really breaks our hearts.
And our goal is to scale this
globally as quickly as we
possibly can.
So with that, I thought I'd end
with a video so you guys
can see the product in use.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Almost every
second of every day, a baby is
born premature or with
low birth weight.
Where they're born makes all
the difference as to what
happens next.
In the developed world, these
babies are placed in an
incubator until they're able
to make it on their own.
But for babies born in parts of
the world without reliable
electricity or modern medical
equipment, desperate mothers
and fathers wrap their babies in
blankets, pack them in hot
water bottles, or place them
under bare light bulbs to keep
them from freezing to death.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
In 2008, graduate students at
Stanford University were
assigned the challenge of
designing a baby incubator for
the people who need
it the most.
Compelled by the cause, these
students abandoned their
career paths, moved to India,
and dedicated themselves to
testing and developing
their design.
After dozens of iterations and
years of testing, the Embrace
infant warmer is being
distributed to disadvantaged
communities and is
saving lives.
Using an innovative phase change
material, a pouch is
heated with a short burst of
electricity or boiling water.
Once activated, it maintains
a constant temperature
for up to six hours.
One unit can save dozens of
lives, and it costs a fraction
of the price of an incubator.
Kurthi's baby weighed less than
four pounds at birth and
was in danger of dying.
An Embrace warmer kept her alive
and three months later,
the baby has doubled in weight
and is doing well.
When baby Long was abandoned at
an orphanage in Beijing, he
weighed only two pounds
and was hypothermic.
The orphanage had no incubator,
but they did have
an Embrace Nest.
After 30 days in the Embrace
warmer, baby Long had
stabilized and put on weight.
He is now a healthy and
happy seven month old.
MALE SPEAKER: Yesterday we saw
that there was a 1.9 kilogram
baby who was wrapped very well
but still had a temperature of
34 degrees centigrade and that
baby was not suckling.
Two hours from the time of
putting it into the Embrace
Nest, the baby spontaneously
started to suck.
The baby is doing well and the
rest of the babies from now on
will be in good care.
DR. KUMAR: The main advantage
of the warmer, the Embrace
warmer, is its portability, its
ease of use, and safety.
There is no separation of
the mother and child.
The mother can feed the baby and
the bonding is improved.
DR. BENAKAPPA: We
had a 900 baby.
We needed to put him
on radiant warmer.
Not a single warmer
was available.
Immediately, we thought of
Embrace and we put the baby
inside that.
So as far as neonatal mortality
in terms of low
birth weight preterm babies,
term babies with very low body
weight-- all of them are
safe and sound and
comfortable in Embrace.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Embrace has
received international
recognition, and now has the
manufacturing infrastructure
in place to rapidly scale
for global distribution.
With your support, Embrace is
poised to help one million
babies in the next five years.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Embrace.
Every child deserves
the opportunity to
live, to grow, to dream.
JANE CHEN: So that's Embrace
in a nutshell.
And if there are any
questions, I'd be
happy to take them.
AUDIENCE: I notice that there's
a liquid on top of the
phase change material.
What's that for?
JANE CHEN: So it serves
two purposes.
One, it's a heat conductor, so
we make sure the heat is
evenly transferred throughout
the whole pouch.
The second thing it does is it
acts as a cushion for the
baby, so even when the wax
hardens, the baby is lying on
a soft surface.
AUDIENCE: So I was just kind of
curious on what some of the
factors are that are limiting
the expansion.
I know you guys have a really
good reputation and your
product's effective, so
I was just kind of
curious what else.
JANE CHEN: Sure.
So I think there's a couple
different things
that go into that.
One is certainly
distribution--
so, figuring out who are our
partners are going to be in
distribution.
And distribution is not so
simple just leaving the
product there.
Even though it's a simple
product, it does require
training, and training not only
of the doctors but of the
nurses, of everyone who
interacts with the product.
Things like making sure the
product is cleaned thoroughly
between every baby, for
example, requires that
constant training.
In addition to just distributing
the product, what
we're also doing is building
education around the product
because our interest is in
the outcome, not just the
technology.
And so if our interest is really
in infant mortality,
then the product gives us an
entry point into these
communities.
And once we're there, we want to
educate around things like
hygiene, nutrition,
breastfeeding-- all the other
really important factors that go
into saving a baby's life.
AUDIENCE: So maybe this
extends into the
distribution question.
So all the pictures I saw
was mostly of hospitals.
JANE CHEN: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: Of hospitals.
So I am thinking that it is used
by hospitals right now.
How are you going to go it at
home, because that you're not
going to anticipate a premature
babies, so you're
not going to buy
it in advance.
So how is that going
to happen?
JANE CHEN: That's a
great question.
So we actually have two versions
of the product.
One is called the Embrace
Nest, which is used in a
clinical setting, and the second
is called the Embrace
Care, and that one is used
in a home setting.
And the difference is one uses
intermittent access to
electricity, and the second
one uses just
entirely hot water.
So the way we plan to get these
into the homes-- we've
started with the clinical
product with the reason of
wanting to get the buy in of the
medical community before
we go into a village setting.
But what happens is, in India,
for example, the government is
actually paying women to give
birth in institutions to bring
down the rate of infant
mortality.
However, even if the woman
gives birth in the
institution, she doesn't have
money to keep her baby there
over a few days So doctors are
discharging these babies at
one kilo sometimes, at 2
and 1/2 pounds or even
smaller than that.
And so they have requested
a product that they can
essentially prescribe to
patients and these patients
can take it home with them.
So that's how we'll start
getting into the home setting,
and we've just began
that initiative.
Over time, what we hope to do
is sell the product directly
to midwives and to community
health care workers.
So if each community health care
worker has one of these
in their kit, then they can
take it from home to home,
take it to one family.
After that family's done with
it, which usually is a month
at most, then the community
health care worker can
sterilize, sanitize it, and can
take it to the next baby.
AUDIENCE: So socially minded,
how do you think about
intellectual property?
Because on the one hand, you'd
like a big juggernaut like
Siemens or GE to copy what you
have and get product out to
babies and help them.
On the other hand, you want to
make sure that they don't do
bad quality jobs of it and that
you're able to innovate
such things.
There's a lot of issues like
that in the drug industry.
I'm curious how you
think about that.
JANE CHEN: That's a
great question.
So we think about
it in two ways.
Yes, if other people copied this
product, perhaps we could
have larger scale in terms
of distribution.
But you're spot on.
What we're worried about is if
it's a local copycat, it's
very likely that it will be
a low quality product.
We actually take a lot of care
to do the manufacturing in a
very rigorous and safe way,
as I said, that meets
international standards.
A lot of testing goes into
each and every product.
Rigorous clinical tests have
been done as well, so we want
to make sure the second rate
product is not introduced into
these communities.
Because if it is and if it
starts hurting babies, that
will just kill this entire
category of devices.
I think the other aspect of this
is also we rely on people
like GE or distribution partners
to get this to the
people, to the end customer.
And if you're working with
for-profit companies who are
making that initial investment
and marketing the device, they
expect a return on it.
And so they're going to want
us to be protected
intellectually.
So you have to think about this
across the entire value
chain and how it gets to
your end customers.
AUDIENCE: Point-- what is your
guys' corporate structure?
Are you for profit, nonprofit,
because you talk about social
enterprise.
What is your---?
JANE CHEN: So we actually have
a unique corporate structure
that's a mix of both a for
profit and a nonprofit.
We started in 2008 as a
nonprofit as a 501(c)(3) and
quickly came to realize
that to do things like
manufacturing and distribution,
even our
clinical studies, we require
capital to do that.
And you could raise it the way
we were in $5,000, $10,000
increments, but it was a very,
very difficult to do that and
focus on the operations.
And so what we ended up doing
was spinning out a for profit
arm of the company that allowed
us to raise capital in
larger increments.
And the way it works is the
nonprofit holds the
intellectual property, it takes
donations to give away
the units to the poorest
communities and provide all of
these educational services
around it.
The for profit then licenses the
technology, manufactures,
sells it to the clinics that can
afford to pay for it-- so
these are still bottom of the
pyramid clinics, but they have
a revenue stream.
They can pay for the product--
and then does future
research and
development for new products.
And so the idea is that by
leveraging private and
philanthropic capital,
we can cover all
segments of the market.
AUDIENCE: One thing I'm always
curious about in
entrepreneurship and technology
innovation, why now?
Like, why is this
happening now?
Why hasn't this been
done before?
And I don't mean it in a bad
way, but very much like what
happened at that sparked this
and why is it successful now?
Why hasn't it been
done before?
JANE CHEN: Yeah.
You know, I am not entirely
sure about that.
But I love getting that
question, because I think it
means you're under a good design
when someone looks at
something and says,
this is so simple.
How come no one's done
this before?
Yeah, it's a really
good question.
Part of it, I think, definitely
is about timing,
and that if you think
about this
issue of infant mortality.
It's getting more attention
internationally in the global
public health community
than ever before.
It's the Millennium Development
goal that we're
the furthest away
from reaching.
I'll give you some stats here.
So of all deaths of children
under five years old, 40% of
them happen in the first 28
days of a child's life.
Now beyond 28 days, vast
improvements have been made
because of vaccines.
That's brought down the death
rate significantly.
But there have been very few, if
any, interventions in that
first 28 days, and that's really
what Embrace is trying
to address here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for giving the speech.
It's really interesting to
learn about your product.
I actually used work and
development before.
So one of the questions I had
for you was how do you get buy
in, and by buy in, I mean
cultural buy in, because a lot
of countries are not open to
having products coming from a
foreign country?
And then also how you get
monetary buy in, because a lot
of developing countries like
to get things for free?
JANE CHEN: So in terms of buy
in, one of the things I really
stressed here was our efforts in
making the product locally
appropriate.
So right after Stanford,
the entire founding
team moved to India.
All of our operations are based
in India, all of our
manufacturing is done in India,
and so I think we're
perceived more as an Indian
company, or at the very least
a hybrid, than an American
company trying to bring in
Western technology into the
market, which is what many of
these incubators are.
And so I think from that
perspective, buy in has not
been so difficult.
I think, however, this is a new
concept and a lot of what
we're doing now is around
thinking through how do we
effect behavior change?
Just because something is needed
as demonstrated by the
number doesn't mean demand
is necessarily there.
And that requires a lot of
education, awareness raising,
marketing, so that's the
part of the process
Embrace is at now.
In terms of monetary buy in,
we really believe in market
mechanisms where they work.
And so in the areas that we
operate, we work with a lot of
private clinics.
And in countries like India,
you see a rise of private
health even in rural settings.
And there, we are very much
selling the product, selling
it at margin.
That's really important for
the organization in our
efforts to become sustainable.
To the segments of the
population that we reach
through our NGO partners, the
ones we know cannot be served
by the market, there we do
give away the product.
But because we accompany it
with so much training and
programs, we ensure that it's
being used-- again, that it's
not just being dumped
at the clinic.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming out.
So I imagine that success
rate is not 100%.
You can correct me if
I'm wrong on that.
Have you found instances where
there have been times where
these children just aren't able
to be saved, and what is
the effect about the perception
of the product when
that happens, and how do
you counteract that?
JANE CHEN: That's a
great question.
Fortunately, we have not seen
that as of yet, or if it's
happened, we haven't
been notified.
We don't follow every case
of usage of the product.
But the fact is, these are
sick babies, these are
vulnerable babies, and there
will be babies who die in this
product because our product
is not a cure all.
It solves some of the problem in
terms of keeping the babies
warm, but oftentimes these
babies need to be
resuscitated, they need oxygen,
they need further care
beyond just the product.
And so I think that's why the
clinical studies for us have
been so critical, to show the
efficacy of the product, to
show the safety, why we follow
very strict processes in our
design and our manufacturing,
so if and when that does
happen, we can go back and
say, here are all the
safeguards that we've
put in place.
And none of this, by the way,
is required by the Indian
government.
Our product doesn't fall under
any regulatory standards.
We've just done this to really
go above and beyond for this
exact reason.
AUDIENCE: I noticed in the
beginning your mission
statement is to bring low cost,
affordable medical devices.
So beyond the incubator, what
are the other products that
you're thinking about
or working on or
are currently testing?
JANE CHEN: So we're really
focused on the maternal child
health care space.
As I said, we've just launched
a second version of the
product that you see today.
So we want to make sure we get
these products right first.
But the way we're thinking about
it is working within the
same space and leveraging those
distribution channels to
bring other technologies
to market.
So a lot of early stage idea.
Nothing I can talk about quite
yet, but it's something we
certainly intend to do.
AUDIENCE: I heard you speak at
SOCAP yesterday as well.
And I think one of the themes
that I saw at SOCAP-- social
capital conference that was
interesting, which I'm curious
about your thoughts.
Once you've proven the efficacy
of a product, it's
almost better for the world
as fast as you can scale.
And in that sense, is there any
thoughts on whether you
want to license it out and start
sort of having contract
manufacturing for helping it
scale and get delivery at a
scale that's beyond your
manufacturing capabilities at
some point?
And how do you make
that decision?
JANE CHEN: I think we're
certainly open to that.
It's kind of step
by step process.
I think when you launch
something like this that is an
entirely new concept, you do
have to micromanage the
process initially to understand
a number of things.
How is it being used?
How do we continue iterating the
product to make sure it's
appropriate each of these
different settings?
Even things like how do we sell
the product, how do we
position it, how do
we price it--
I don't think anyone will do
as good of a job as the
organization that
founded this.
So I think once we have figured
that out then the next
step is to work with local
distributors, and then beyond
that-- yeah, licensing is
definitely a possibility.
AUDIENCE: What is Embrace's
greatest need right now?
JANE CHEN: What is our
greatest need?
A number of different needs.
So definitely, great partners.
That's really how we're
going to scale.
We don't have the capacity
to go into each of these
countries and so we rely on NGO
partners that have really
strong infrastructure in place
so they can help with that
scaling process.
Connections to--
again, to NGOs, to governments,
to people in the
public health community who
can help to scale this.
We're always looking for
more human resources.
So, I don't know where
Will went.
One of our interns
works here now.
We have a really fun internship
program that we
have every year.
And then, of course, funding--
so funding on our nonprofit
side to continue scaling these
programs and to get more
products out there.
AUDIENCE: I saw that when you
guys started, you had a really
small team.
And I was curious to know what
kind of background you came
from, whether it was engineering
or business or
design, something like that?
JANE CHEN: I personally did
my MBA and a public policy
degree, and I had experience
before that in consulting and
then with non-profits.
There was a mix of nonprofit
and private sector.
But I think I've come to realize
is you don't need to
be a designer to
do design work.
Anyone can be a designer.
And this design process I showed
is just an organized
process for creativity.
And so our product is
a mix of engineers--
or our team is a mix of
engineers, of clinical folks,
operational folks.
It's just a really fun
multidisciplinary team that's
been able to bring
this to market.
AUDIENCE: Maybe I missed this
because I came a little bit
later, but what are some of
your success metrics like
number of children saved?
As in like growth, how many
units are being purchased?
JANE CHEN: Right now, it's all
about the number of units
being purchased or distributed,
as well as the
number of babies who've
used those.
So each product can be used
by multiple babies.
That's the metric that
we're looking at.
We're also trying to establish
the metrics to look at within
our educational programs-- for
example, how many people are
touched by those.
And over time, through more
studies, how has the incidence
of hypothermia been reduced
among this population?
And when we have enough numbers,
then looking at
things like mortality and
morbidity, how we've been able
to impact those.
AUDIENCE: Going across the
design thinking philosophy--
how long did it take?
If you look at step one to the
final step, how long did you
spend in kind of each of those
phases and which one did you
spend the most time in?
JANE CHEN: Let's see.
It's probably taken
five years.
So it's a process
that never ends.
It's iterative, so we continue
to iterate on the product all
the time as we find new
things on the market.
I think that's a really
important aspect of design
thinking is this innovation
never ends.
You can always make the product
better, and we're were
always listening for
customer feedback.
And being in the field, so
we're able to do that.
I think, though, as I said the
most important part of that
process is really that
point of view.
So who's your user and
what's the need?
It sounds simple.
But by shifting the focus, in
this case, away from the
doctors and the medical
practitioners to a simple
enough product that could
eventually be used in the home
setting, that really guided the
entire direction of the
product and the organization.
AUDIENCE: You're in a really
interesting space, because
it's non-profit and for profit
at the same time.
And I was curious to know what
are some of the challenges you
think are unique to that space,
or something that
you've overcome or
struggled with?
JANE CHEN: You mean in terms of
being a hybrid structure or
in doing both?
Sorry, we just had a long
meeting about this yesterday.
My colleague Pria is sitting in
the audience, so she's on
the nonprofit side of the
organization and I'm on the
for profit side.
I think that's what's really
important, I mean, in terms of
legal structure and
contracts--
that can be figured out-- but
making sure the teams are in
constant communication, that
there's alignment, and that
they continue to be aligned over
time is really critical.
And it's actually difficult in
the sense that we have one
organization, part of the
organization, that's sitting
in the US, and another part
of the organization that's
sitting in India.
And so you have to be really
proactively communicating all
at the same time to make sure
the left arm and the right arm
knows what the other
side is doing.
And the whole idea behind this
is two entities together will
be much stronger than either
of them individually.
But to make that work well,
it's all about execution,
ultimately, in communication.
AUDIENCE: This is sort of more
generally about when you're
building up the company
and when you
decided to be a nonprofit.
When you're fund raising in the
start and trying to get
sort of bootstrapped and move
up to, like, raising funds,
what were your challenges and
how did you learn and adapt to
what you needed to do?
JANE CHEN: I think initially
it's always difficult as a
startup to prove your
credibility.
I think because we're a products
company raising money
for product development it's
actually very difficult.
I think it's easier once you
have a program out there, you
can show impact.
But if you're raising money
for years of product
development in a nonprofit
model, it's a little unusual
and can be quite difficult.
But I would say persistence is
the way you overcome it.
So I always say in my books no
means maybe and maybe means
yes, so never take
no for an answer.
And over time, once you start
building a core group of
funders, they start spreading
the word about your work.
And so I think that those
relationships become
absolutely critical in
the early days of
doing that fund raising.
AUDIENCE: This is a question
for the observation phase.
So I'm assuming that once you
went to the community, that's
probably where you found the
most information about the
context and environment
of people.
I just want to know what
techniques or tools did you
guys use in order to bring--
to reveal the most interesting
discoveries and which helped
influence the design
of the product?
And from a cultural perspective,
were people
comfortable with you applying
those techniques to ask them
about personal experiences or
how they live in their homes?
Was there that pushback from the
culture, because if you're
not from that culture,
maybe it's a
stranger, they look different?
So was it a kind of
cultural pushback?
JANE CHEN: So a lot of it ranged
from just observation,
sitting there observing, that's
it-- just being a
silent observer and watching how
these people interacted,
not just with regards to babies,
but in their day to
day lives to understand
the overall context.
We also did a lot of focus
groups and we did individual
interviews, as well as
with groups of women.
We even had sessions where we
asked them to co-create with
us, so we gave them materials
and asked them to design or
sketch and help us understand
how they were
thinking about things.
So there are a number
of tools.
The cultural sensitivity is--
there definitely are.
We had to have translators go
with us into the field.
And when we brought people
who were local, we'd get
information that was
much richer.
The other thing we realized was
the gender disparity or
the discomfort in talking about
some of these issues are
really sensitive with
men versus women.
And so initially, I had
translators that were men, and
then I bought ones
that were women.
You'd see this huge difference
in how open the women were
willing to be.
I also I think that trust just
takes time to build.
And so the communities where
we've gone back over and over,
they've began to trust
us as a partner.
Those are definitely areas
where we get the richest
information.
And that just takes
time to build.
AUDIENCE: You had mentioned that
there were no safety or
regulatory burdens to
overcome in India.
Is that universally true or are
there are places where the
regulatory landscape is
more of a burden?
JANE CHEN: They are.
So India right now is the
process of, I think, figuring
out and articulating what that
regulatory landscape is.
So there is a drug controller,
for example.
There are certain medical
devices are regulated under
that, but ours doesn't fall
under any category.
But I think that's going
to quickly change over
the next few years.
AUDIENCE: There's many needs
within the world.
How did you decide that
this was the one
you wanted to pursue.
And then what was a turning
point for your whole team to
say, this is going to
happen, we're all
going to move to India?
JANE CHEN: So this one-- you may
have missed the beginning
of the presentation.
It came about through a class
project, actually.
So it was a challenge that was
posed to a few of us taking
this class together, and that's
how everything started.
But in terms of how we decided
to move forward with it, I
think the end of the class
came and we thought if we
don't take this forward, no
one else is going to.
We're sitting on a
great idea here.
We really wanted to see
it through to the end.
So we started applying for
different grants and there's
one in particular that
required a two year
commitment.
And so once we got that, we knew
we were locked in for a
couple of years.
And slowly one by one, everyone
either quit their
jobs or graduated.
And as a team together, we
decided to do this full time
and move to India, and have
grown since then from four
people to 60 people.
So it's been really fun to see
the growth of the company and
building the organization
has been one of the most
interesting things for me.
Cool.
Well, thank you guys so much.
If you guys want to stay updated
on Embrace, we have a
sign up sheet here.
Please sign up for
our newsletter.
We would love to keep you
posted on our progress.
We also have an event
coming up on
November 19th at Stanford.
So again, if you sign up for the
newsletter, we'll give you
more information on that.
It's going to be at the
design school there.
We're going to be doing some
really fun activities around
the design thinking process that
I introduced here today.
So thank you again for being
here, and we hope that you'll
get involved in some way.